[Music]
hey everybody
super great to be here today thanks so
much for having me I'm going to talk
today about independent deployment for
the front end specifically when it comes
to single page applications and one way
that you can achieve this using tools
like docker and kubernetes so before I
talk about what's possible I want to
talk about where we are today probably
you have a diagram in your office that
looks something like this or maybe
you've read it in an architecture book
at some point the base of your diagram
it begins with your microservices writes
each of these lives in Nice bounded
context they may be owned the data
that's you're operating on they can be
deployed and maintained independently
and you have an autonomous team that
owns and operates them end to end so far
so good on top of that we have maybe an
API gateway that handles how you're
going to access these things and then on
the very top of this you know immaculate
architecture diagram is the UI layer I
like to think about it like the icing on
the cake because that's kind of like the
best part but in reality when you look
at this and you see it in in an
architecture book oftentimes you think
is that all you're gonna tell me it's
just like this box at the top and that's
that's the only details I get out of it
and it can feel like you know these days
the UI layer is becoming responsible for
more and more and yet all we get in
terms of information on how it should be
organized is this one big box on the top
and a natural question that can come up
is why didn't we just naturally start to
break this down like we did
microservices who here has ever been
asked by your boss your CTO why can't we
just have Micro Services in the UI
anybody has have you been asked this I
think it's completely normal right and
you're like it doesn't work that way
right and there are a couple of made
reasons for that the first of which
being well cross component communication
is a bit different right we have
different frameworks we're not just
talking with data but we're talking also
with more complex objects we also know
that visual consistency is super
important for us maybe you know you see
an API you get some document
on it which was made by back-end team
it's in a micro service and it doesn't
really matter that it's inconsistent
maybe to you as a developer you care a
lot but the user is never gonna see that
inconsistent API so that's one way that
these also differ and finally most of
our bill tools assume that everything
that I need to build and run my app is
gonna be available at Build time but
that's not exactly the way we want to
build distributed systems right so all
of these things impose upon us some
different limitations that make them
unique when compared to how micro
services work in the world of back-end
and as we have probably all felt a bit
if you worked in a team that starts to
grow and then it keeps growing and
growing some more you're like is this
gonna be sustainable to keep doing
things that way that I have always been
doing it becomes challenging because you
have one way to get to prod maybe we'll
use some strategies like feature toggles
or you practice trunk based development
but the end you've got one path we also
have the topic of getting buy-in from
more people the bigger the codebase the
more developers the more people you need
to get on board when you want to make a
change and sometimes this can lead to
stagnation because getting enough people
on board is really really hard to do it
also creates a single point of failure
how many times has it happened that you
deployed something and a totally
unrelated change that you promised to QA
was not gonna affect anything else
resulted in a totally random bug you
just could not possibly foresee and you
might be thinking tests are the answer
to this obviously mónica if you had the
right test pyramid all filled out with
all of your tests well then you could
just deploy all the time and you
wouldn't have an issue but we all know
that having a reliable test especially
the higher you go up in the pyramid it
is very difficult to do that and you're
gonna spend a lot of time maintaining
them we also have the topic of shared
tools some people love to maintain
webpack I don't
that's okay but but do you really want
to have people in your team and their
only job is to maintain and you know
upgrade everything all the time with all
these new releases that are coming out
and at the end things just get slower
you have more people more communication
and things start to slow down and the
reality is we're working against
Conway's law as you probably know if
you've heard of this term before when
you design a system you're very likely
to copy the way that your teams and
communication structures are set up in
your company but here we are having this
cross-functional teams that are men's
who own something in two end but that
vertical slice of ownership ends at the
front end right and then they need to go
into the UI layer to communicate with
all these people and get the job done so
how do other people solve this problem
it's the buzzword of I don't know the
last couple of years
micro front-ends rights it sounds a very
sexy you're like it's micro like micro
services but for the front end and your
boss loves it right because they're like
finally you're listening to me
and yeah it's it promises us that we can
decompose the UI into blocks we can
deploy individually
sounds like the panacea to all of our
problems well as you may know if you
have ever watch to talk about micro
friends and guessing a lot of you have
there are so many different approaches
no two companies do it the same and
sometimes it can be hard to find out is
there a standard or best practice or
anything like that and and the main
question the main thing that
distinguishes between them is where does
integration happen and which point of
integration makes sense for you is going
to depend a lot on the requirements that
you have so you can do this from links
you have one app it links to another app
through a hyperlink that's micro
front-ends for some people that's very
nice it's probably the technically
simplest way you can get away with it
you also have built time integration
this is common in a mono repo so I have
all my nice packages but when I build it
all comes together because that's how my
tools are organized and then I deploy
everything to production is this a month
is this microfinance maybe
up to you to decide you also have
server-side integration so the server's
responsible for bringing together all of
the artifacts and you have client-side
integration so I click something I
request something I put it in the Dom
more or less all of these different
kinds of approaches have their own
benefits and their own drawbacks I don't
have time to go into all of them and
maybe you'll learn more about that
tomorrow but the fact of the matter is
when I researched a lot of these things
I felt like they really neglected a lot
of the things that we believe in front
end are kind of important right we want
our bundle sizes to be reasonably small
we want a good user experience so people
don't need to reload the page when they
navigate we want that the developers
experience is really great because we
are so spoiled in the front-end for
amazing tools and when something doesn't
work just the way we wanted to we're
gonna complain on Twitter what about
micro services I mean one of the things
that I found a lot when I looked at
these solutions is we kind of took the
micro from my cursor verses and we
thought that was enough but in reality
there are so many best practices and
great ways you can shoot yourself in the
foot by just breaking up your app
willy-nilly
for example development and production
parity so many of these options just say
I develop my thing I'll see how it looks
once I deploy it I don't really have a
reasonable way to run it on my local
machine and deploying independently
maybe there in different packages but
they're gonna get together at Build time
and we still tend to centralize a lot of
these things so this made me sad because
my boss asked me Monica can't we have
micro services for the front end and I
said I will try so in the meantime I
found all of these things and I was not
super happy with them so meanwhile at my
company we started to introduce a suite
of new tools the first one that we began
to introduce a stalker how many people
here are running docker in production
okay so this is like actually more than
I expect it to be honest which is pretty
cool
so this talk is even applicable for you
in your personal life and so darker
allows you to bundle together your
application in a way you can distribute
it and what's neat about this
as developers we can read our dockerfile
we can ship it and we can actually have
control over the image the things that
are installed on it and so on that's
pretty neat then on top of this we have
kubernetes and kubernetes is one of
these things that is infamous for being
hard to explain it's billed as container
orchestration and what this basically
means is I have containers and I need to
control them somehow they need to talk
to each other
they need to replicate I need more
copies maybe one of them goes down and I
need to bring them back up again and
kubernetes takes care of that for us and
one thing that is super cool about
kubernetes is that you can define your
infrastructure in yeah Mille so it's
actually in data so it's lower on the
ladder of abstraction than if you were
to program all of it and not write any
tests for it so that's kind of cool and
then kind of coupled with kubernetes we
have helm and helm gives us a lot of
capabilities but one of the most
important ones is that we can take a lot
of the repetitive bits out of our
manifests and we can put them into
variables that we can later interpolate
depending on if we're in dev we're in
production or some other environment and
I should mention both both kubernetes
and helm can do so much more than we
need here but something that I think is
so cool about this is that you only need
certain parts of each of these things to
achieve what we want to achieve so you
don't need to know like the deep depths
of kubernetes in order to accomplish
something meaningful so looking at this
and spending some time really learning
this I thought can this help me is there
some way that the things being
introduced by dr. Cooper Nettie's and
helm could some of some other things I
didn't really like about the micro
front-ends approaches that I had seen so
far so looking at the basic anatomy of a
web app I mean I'm sure a lot of you
guys are working on Web Apps that
probably kind of look like this so you
have your site navigation and you have
the main stuff right it's like pretty
standard and I was thinking to myself
why can't I just take this this part on
the outside the host application it's
going to be deployed the way that it
would be absolutely anyways
run
inside of our kubernetes cluster but I
can take out a part in the middle
whether it's one page or another page
and I can make this independently
deployable I don't necessarily need to
deploy my entire app together because
this this fragment is a component it
needs some data but more or less it
operates on its own so how does this
actually work and there's a concept in
kubernetes called ingress and ingress
basically allows you to route traffic
that is coming from the outside Internet
and given a hostname and a path you can
direct this traffic to a service that is
living inside of your cluster so I was
like ok I just bring up a service for
each of these parts of my application
and let's see if it works so I want to
show you guys actually how this works in
code and go a little bit deeper we're
gonna start by looking actually at what
the app does what kind of communication
is possible and we're going to look at
that in the browser then we're also
going to look at what does it look like
to bring in a component from somewhere
else from from another server then we're
gonna look very briefly at the
configuration there is a lot of llamó
you can see there's there's a lot of
data here but we're gonna see what what
interesting bits we can find and if the
internet works we're gonna do a
deployments so let's let's give this a
shot and so first things first let's
come over to our web interface so here
you can see I have two boxes so I have
my host application here and I have my
fragment application here okay these
things are both coming from different
services that are running in suit side
of my kubernetes cluster what's neat
about this is that from the user
standpoint it's completely normal
I'm able to send data inside of my
little fragment and I'm able to do the
same from inside my fragment to the
outside so I have bi-directional
communication I want to do things like
styling so I'm able to do this here I'm
using CSS and J's but you can also ship
separate assets if that's something that
you want to do how does this actually
work well
when I go to a specific route I'm going
to get some information I know this is
so tiny
does it get bigger it does I'm here yeah
so so I'm here in my in the the route
that is going to my service and this
gives me information about the bundle I
need and the name of the component and I
can just load that JavaScript cool what
does this look like now in code so here
you can see that I have two totally
separate repositories if I go into one
of them you can see I have everything I
think I should have here I have my disk
I have my node modules etc and when I
actually open up my two separate files
for the first thing that you'll notice
is I'm actually using a helper called
async component which is going to create
a component for me and what's neat about
this is yeah I'm gonna be loading
everything I'm going to be loading
everything remotely but ultimately this
component operates the same way as
literally any react component would I
have my fragments I'm able to pass it in
data I'm able to pass in callbacks
exactly what you would expect so from
the developer experience standpoint it's
actually not so different than working
on a normal react app despite the fact
that all of my tasks and everything is
running in a local cluster on my machine
and this is actually inside of docker at
the moment and the way I get it in is by
using mounting the the disk directory
into the container cool so what happens
when I want to make a change so I want
to change this message from hello
beautiful people - hello jeaious
Congress okay I want to write this and I
want to see how this actually works so
you see it made this update and even
though I'm running inside of docker the
change is instant it's exactly the same
as you would expect nice so let's
actually let's change this
and let's deploy it so I once you
actually add whoops add this and well
that's fine I can do this
hello the best commit message you've
ever seen promoting good good practices
in public as is my sacred duty nice so
we're gonna push this and we're going to
come back to this and like to in like
two minutes once the deployment has
happened in the meantime let's go back
add two to the talk itself great so
right now what's happening is this is
going to run inside of circle CI it's
gonna bring up a new pod that contains
my code what are some of the winds that
we get simply by having this set up the
first thing is that we end up with
better technical autonomy for our teams
imagine you're in a team and you have
the opportunity to define for yourself
what what kind of machine am i running
on maybe I don't want to use node maybe
I just want to use nginx but I get to
choose you also have the fact that you
as a team get to own a fully vertical
part of your stack so you own not only
the micro services you own the tooling
you own what's happening in the
front-end and you actually get to own
this slice as opposed to needing to go
there and kind of like barter with all
of the developers over what gets
deployed next you deploy one thing at a
time like really one thing not one
massive thing but one one part and a
major win for this is that you have the
option to have more granular and safer
releases so instead of rolling out your
whole app at once and maybe doing that
gradually you can roll out individual
parts and if you're working in a
business scenario where being up all the
time is super important like in my
scenario I'm working in finance it is so
important that things don't go down so
being able to make them smaller and less
risky is very very critical
you also don't necessarily need to run
the whole app right so we all know
things like web pack things like just
they get slower the bigger your app gets
so what this allows you to do is bring
take out part of that and run and
operate on a smaller piece and finally
you don't have to take your whole app
and do this you can take just the parts
that are interesting or relevant for you
with the places you might maybe want
more safety or more autonomy you can
take a page a section an individual
component whatever level of granularity
is appropriate for your scenario all
right now we get to the danger zone I
think this is something that is really
easy to have happen if you apply all of
the front-end best practices you're
familiar with and you just take them and
you say I'm going to keep doing that but
then I'm gonna deploy this bit
separately you know you kind of don't
get to don't don't get to have both
parts so there are just a couple of
small points I want to make that will
help you kind of change your your
mindset a little bit in terms of the
architecture you need for a setup like
this the first thing is that central
configuration is something we want to
avoid when it's feasible in my example
we are using a router that is still in
the house application but as this grows
and scales there's a good chance that we
would want to take this out and deploy
it separately then we want to also
separate code that changes at a
different cadence if you have one team
in the code base in some area that is
moving really fast super experiments or
you have another team that is maybe more
cautious because their code is much more
sensitive if something goes wrong
there's a good chance that you want to
separate these things because otherwise
you will have either technical conflicts
or team conflicts and finally when it
comes to having consistent UI if this is
something that is important to you I
would suggest to invest in either
building a design system or using
something that already exists and not
relying on custom CSS because this is
just the path to disaster and all right
so at this point in the talk I want to
answer a question that is probably on
the mind of at least 50% of the people
in this room if not more and that is
this one is this totally over engineered
so the first time that I ever explained
this concept to another developer he's
working at a different company with
quite a different set up and different
size he told me
it sounds like dropping bombs on ants
and I was like okay I can relate to that
I can understand how you feel and there
are a couple of things I think you
should just keep in mind when you're
evaluating whether you want to break
down your your large application the
first thing is that your solution is so
contextual there are so many talks that
are going to be happening over the next
rest of the conference and there are
different solutions for different
companies with different team setups
everything is unique so whether this is
a right approach for you depends on so
many factors you don't need to think you
know because I'm watching this talk
because I'm up here on stage that this
is exactly the right solution for me it
depends a lot on context the other thing
is that the tools are not the end game
so doctrine kubernetes are very cool and
definitely something I would encourage
you to look into but let's be honest
maybe they're not even going to be here
in five years maybe we're gonna have
something way better by then I hope so I
mean that's the point of technology
right we keep advancing and if we just
get married to the idea of how using
these tools we're missing out on the
benefits which is that we can architect
our application differently so that it's
more modular and more resilient to
change in different areas and finally as
I said it's not all or nothing maybe
look for some opportunities in your app
and say hey would this benefit from more
safety or more granularity or more
autonomy so let's have a quick look back
at our deployments internets please if
anybody is on the speaker internet mic
please stop that oh it worked that was
surprising okay
fabulous okay so our message has updated
okay
and if I run cube CT I'll get pods this
is the command that is going to get the
pod pod is what wraps a container in
kubernetes you can see that my host
application has been running for 11 days
but my individual fragment has been
running for only 3 minutes so you can
see I was able to deploy that part of
the application totally separately from
the main app nice cool so I just want to
come to the last point here the last
thing that I really want you to take
away from this talk it's not that I
think that micro front-ends whether it's
the solution or any other solution is
absolutely the right choice for
everybody as I said there is context
there is the way your team is working
there are so many different things it's
also not that you should drop everything
and learn doctor and kubernetes because
those are cool technologies but maybe
they want to be around forever it's more
important instead than I think we as
developers who are working on the front
end be open to learning tools from
different areas that aren't necessarily
created by our own community and I want
to encourage you guys just to be
open-minded and to go out sort of your
comfort zone in order to really grasp
what possibilities are there for what I
want to build so many times when it
comes to operations deployment we say
it's ops problem and by giving this away
to them the reality is is that we miss
out on a lot of chances to optimize
things and to understand what kind of
capabilities could be in our hands if we
just decided to learn the basics of
these tools but maybe not every
front-end developer is so interested in
but I hope why you're listening to this
talk is because you're different you're
interested in these tools and I would
encourage you it's totally attainable
you can do it and thank you
okay one last thing and I have some
resources here just if you are curious
I'll also post the sample code up on
github later and if your interest in
this topic do attend tomorrow's talks
there's going to be a talk on micro apps
and there's going to be a talk about dr.
Cooper Danny's anode which are going to
go way deeper into those topics so do
check them up
[Applause]
[Music]